اعلنت وكاله الانباء السعوديه ان المملكه
ستستضيف اليوم السبت اجتماعا لممثلي عدد
من الدول بشان الازمه الاوكرانيه واشارت
الى ان الحكومه السعوديه تتطلع يسهم
الاجتماع في تعزيز الحوار والتعاون على
المستوى الدولي بشان حل الازمه الاوكرانيه
وبما يجنب العالم مزيدا من التدعيه
الانسانيه والامنيه والاقتصاديه وياتي ذلك
في وقت النقله فيه وكاله عن مصدر بوزاره
الخارجيه الروسيه ان السعوديه ابلغت روسيا
بانها ستطلعها على نتائج الاجتماع اما
الخارجيه الصينيه
فاكذا المم
ثل الاستعداد بجيل للعمل مع المجتمع
الدولي لمواصله لعب دور بناء في تعزيز
التسويه السياسيه للازمه الاوكرانيه
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
الاجتماع الذي ستشهده مدينه جده السعوديه
بشان اوكرانيا بالمهم للغايه
عنا مصير الملايين
في معادله السلام حسب تعبيره
سيبدا في جده اجتماع لمستشري رؤساء الدول
وممثلي وزاره الخارجيه بشان صيغه السلام
سيتم تمثيل العديد من البلدان بما في ذلك
دول الجنوب العالمي هذا مهم للغايه لانه
في مسائل مثل الامن الغذائي يعتمد مصير
ملايين الاشخاص في افريقيا واسيا واجزاء
اخرى من العالم بشكل مباشر على مدى سرعه
العالم في تنفيذ معادله السلام انا ممتن
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه على هذه المنصه
للمفاوضات
قال رئيسه مركز الخليج الابحاثي عبد
العزيز بن صقر ان اجتماع جده تشاوري بشان
اوكرانيا سينعقد بمشاركه اكثر من 30 دوله
بينها الولايات المتحده والصينه واضاف في
مقابله مع الجزيره الاجتماع يهدف الى
الخروج برؤيه موحده لمقاربه الازمه
الاجتماع هو على مستوى مستشارين امن
الوطني او القومي كما يسمى في بعض الدول
ولذلك هذا يعطي دلالتين مهمه اولا الدلاله
الاولى بان هذه الموضوع اوكرانيا وروسيا
وهذه الازمه هي ازمه دوليه لها تاثيرات
بشكل كبير على مستوى الامن القومي لدول
عديده اوروبا وبقيه دول العالم والنقطه
الثانيه ان هذا يناقش الاطروحات التي طرحت
هنالك مبادرات مختلفه التركيه لها مبادره
واوكرانيا كان لديها مشروع طرحته هي في
السابق الصين لديها يعني ايضا اطروحه فهذا
سوف يناقش كافه المبادرات